unlike a good binge watch seriously is
there anything better
no daredevil season two so daredevil
season two is season two with the
Netflix Marvel series daredevil we
haven't seen daredevil season 1 yet oh
my god do that right now
season ones resolved now in season 2
there are a list of new threats and
baddies that come to Hell's Kitchen so
now daredevil has to suit up and once
against Davis it in all the likeability
that Matt Murdock does I love the dude
that had to play daredevil Charlie Cox
is just as something likable about this
guy just see the weight of the world on
his guy's shoulders it's classic story
in season 2 he's trying to balance
friends and who does know about him
being daredevil with who doesn't and
romancing screw-up poor guy let's talk
about the new threats in this season
first of all the Punisher isn't it Frank
Castle has come to Hell's Kitchen played
by Jon Bernthal to this dude he's no
stranger to playing really unstable
people who were just kind of they need
to kill folks he was such a good choice
as Frank Castle after seeing it in
execution he brings a humanity to this
dude who do that I mean he straight up
kills people it's great to see daredevil
and him just clash their ideologies just
like Daredevils like you don't do that
in my city and he just doesn't really
give a and they live it up too I
mean when you have the Punisher in your
show you know it's gonna be pretty
bloody and it is blood there are copious
amounts of blood it never really crossed
a line into gratuitous I just felt like
they were living up to Punisher name
it's like a yeah it's The Punisher what
are we gonna do have it be pg-13 yeah
don't do that
and Elektra has come back into Matt
Murdock's life so there is that element
also do you have a romance and another
villain or at least antihero and then
you have the Punisher who's an antihero
what is daredevil has his hands full in
this season however I will say that in
terms of synergy I felt season one was
flawless and I might have had season 1
itis when I was watching it I go back
and watch it maybe I'll be like ah
didn't really flow as much as I thought
but in season 2 you have the Punisher
and then you have a lecture and these
are two unrelated things and when the
Punisher is getting is shine for the
first three or four episodes you're like
oh my god I'm in it this dude is awesome
this is going to be a great season and
then the Punisher kind of takes a
backseat and that wraps up and then you
have Elektra and then you're like Oh
lecture is pretty sweet and you're
we invested in that and then electric
kind of takes a back seat and then
Punisher comes back into it when is the
characters flow and ebb like that in the
foreground then the background vice
versa but it never really has the
synergy you wanted to see in season two
that's not to say season two isn't good
it's not to say season two isn't great
because it is great I just feel like the
brainstorming session for season two
they were like well we want to do the
Punisher that's great and half the room
was like we wanted to do Elektra and
they decided to do both without finding
a way to have both work together as well
as I feel like they wanted them to work
together I guess in essence this feels
like a Frankenstein version of season
two and three just chopped up in itself
and if I'm going to throw this out there
I figure I might as well throw this out
there at this point I feel like Elektra
Sark actually plays into season two and
where they were going with season two
better than The Punisher which breaks my
heart because I love the character The
Punisher in here I thought he was
masterfully done but neither electorate
nor the Punisher really fill the void
left by Wilson Fisk maybe he's just I
miss Wilson Fisk I do feel like
daredevil season two is a good
introduction for the Punisher I feel
like somehow he's gonna get his own
spin-off show I don't know if that was
the point I don't know if that was the
plan when they were putting him in
season two but I do feel like at this
point he's gonna be such a fan favorite
that fans are gonna be like dude he
should totally get his own show then
they're gonna work it out and be like
yeah it's probably not a bad idea I
guess we can't do a review in the show
and not talk about the action because
holy God the action in this show is
every bit as good as its film quality
right here for you to binge watch for 13
episodes my favorite action sequence in
a movie or a TV show in years was in
daredevil season one it was that fight
down the hallway it was either episode
two or three it's one of the coolest
things I've ever seen and it locks you
right into the show you're like I'm not
even given this show up ever until it
stops until it ends so no my god how
exciting was the action in season 2 I
could watch daredevil and Electra kick
copious amounts of ass and I just I was
just there it's like yeah give me more
give me more give me more
lots of daredevil Elektra and ninjas
it's the fight ninjas in the end
daredevil season 2 I didn't like as much
as daredevil season 1 but I still loved
marathoning daredevil season 2 I thought
the characters were great I thought the
main characters were great I thought the
villains were great I thought the
supporting cast is still fantastic it
does slow down a bit after episode 4
that's when you really start seeing that
maybe the synergy that they wanted to
have between
Punisher and Elektra and both of those
unrelated arcs didn't really flow as
well as they wanted it to you can't deny
this is some of the best marathon worthy
entertainment that you're gonna find out
there I can't wait for season 3 I can't
wait for more Jessica Jones I can't wait
for more Luke Cage as a Luke Cage
trailer that played at the end of this I
immediately got excited for Luke Cage
and if you're looking forward to more
daredevil it has arrived you should
watch it right now I'm interested to
hear what you guys think of it so
daredevil season 2 you have you seen it
what did you think about it and what did
you like better season one or season two
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more